how do you tell one of the most
financially successful franchises in
history well sometimes you don't rise of
the Beast fix some problems with the
Michael Bay films but introduce some of
its own
the original Transformers movie was
about a boy in his car the boy being Sam
Witwicky the story of the original Three
Transformers films was largely told
through his eyes starting from
Transformers Age of Extinction at the
point of view shifted to a more
middle-aged perspective through Texas
inventor Katie Diego these characters
and their supporting players were never
interesting but worse than that they
were often surrounded by grating comedic
relief players and the movies were
overloaded with broad goofy caricatures
mugging for Laughs Transformers rise of
the Beast doesn't necessarily Excel with
its protagonists but human leaves Noah
and Elena are far less annoying than
summon Kate rise of the Beast does a
better job of intertwining Noah into the
main robots action although Elena is
often given the cold shoulder and
over-the-top examples of comic relief
human characters are kept to a bare
minimum granted there's still too much
focus in this Transformers movie on
disposable human beings instead of
robots but at least rise of the Beast
has a good sense to make its humans more
tolerable
with rise of the Beast new visual
effects ground has been broken for the
franchise and not necessarily in a good
way for the first time the visual
effects house industrial lighter magic
is not involved with realizing the
various CG robots this company even
stuck around with the Autobots and
Decepticons through bumblebee yet they
weren't able to work on a massive movie
like rise of the Beast with a slew of
robots and Mechanical Animals an
assortment of different visual effects
houses was instead recruited to realize
the characters of Rise of the Beast
including wetter digital the New Zealand
company famous for its work on Avatar
and Lord of the Rings unfortunately the
CG used for the array of robots in Rise
of the Beast is not wetter's finest the
biggest issue is that Optimus Prime and
Company often looks strangely rubbery
and divorced from the live-action
backdrops a key climatic moment where
the evil Scourge picks their rub is
undercut by just how fake the whole
thing looks the characters don't seem to
be on the same Planet let alone in the
same scene but this is in sharp contrast
to the original Transformers movies
which featured terrible robot designs
but did find work incorporating the
various aliens into real world settings
despite years of visual effects
advancements since the first movie Rise
of the Beast features shockingly subpass
CG on its robotic leads many mainstream
films have a reductive view of what's
on-screen sexuality should be too many
mass-market features have used sexiness
as an excuse to dehumanize people rather
than flesh out characters casein points
the original Michael Bay Transformers
movies whether various lead ladies
sometimes only existed to be o God by
the camera performers reduced to body
parts for the enjoyment of the male gays
while their characters were never given
interesting personalities or subplots to
inhabit is that your girlfriend mm-hmm
X it was a recurring problem in these
movies that encapsulated The
unimaginative approach many mainstream
features have towards the concept of
sexuality thankfully Transformers rise
of the Beast a Voice's problem with
camera work and editing that never
reduces the female characters so being
just something that people can drool
over one unexpected virtue of the
original Michael Bay Transformers movies
with a heavy emphasis on professional
voice actors to breathe life into the
various robotic characters granted their
lines could have sometimes used a few
extra passes in the writer's room this
looks like a cool place to kick it
what is that how do you learn to talk
like that still it was cool that
performance like Tom Kenny Charlie Adler
and Frank Welker were the default picks
for Transformers in the live-action
movies unfortunately that tactic has
largely been abandoned for Transformers
rise of the Beast which is said
obviously cast celebrities for all the
robots no matter how big or small the
role is not all the famous voices in
this installment are inherently bad with
Michelle Yo's work as airraiser being
one of the standout's elements however
it's puzzling that someone with the
caliber of Coleman Domingo was hired to
voice just a handful of lines delivered
by Unicron meanwhile there's nothing in
Liza koshy's RC Performance that
couldn't have been accomplished by
professional voice actor like Chris
summer worst of all as Pete Davidson's
performance as Mirage which so
overwhelmingly recalls the real-life
version of Davidson that it proves
distracting wow that was corny when I
said it out loud the Michael Bay
Transformers movies are marked by the
kind of frantic and hyperactive editing
and camera work choices that it becomes
synonymous with the director combined
with the often indecipherable designs of
the various robots many of the big
action sequences were outright
incoherent 2017's Transformers The Last
Knight took things to an even lower Low
by employing a constantly shifting
aspect ratio that would change from one
shot to the next a byproduct of the
movie being partially shot with IMAX
cameras it was a headache inducing
elements that cemented how and engaging
the visual landscape of the franchise
was thankfully Transformers rise of the
Beast hops for crispr framing and more
coherent images that make it easier to
digest the various fight scenes but that
doesn't mean there aren't unique visual
defects in Rise of the Beast especially
when it comes to the often choppy
editing and big set pieces like the
early car chase however at least the
audience is always aware of what's
happening in a single frame those two
qualities alone put rise of the beasts
heads and shoulders above the often
incoherent installments like the last
Knight
one weird fixture of the Michael Bay
Transformers movies was how these
lengthy toy commercials also attracted
such prestigious performers for key
supporting roles after John Turturro
played Seymour Simmons in the original
Transformers the subsequent installments
in this series kept finding roles for
comically overqualified actors to
inhabit Francis McDormand showed up in
Transformers Dark of the Moon as a Stern
government official or Anthony Hopkins
as a round in Transformers the last
night Stanley Tucci manages to snag two
different roles in the franchise one is
a conniving business Mo Golden Age of
Extinction and then as Arthurian wizard
Merlin in the last night these actors
were never delivering their greatest
performances in the Transformers movies
but there was an undeniable level of
morbid entertainment to be had in
watching such legendary actors navigate
the nonsensical stories of these
features unfortunately Transformers rise
of the Beast never even tries to emulate
this quality of the earlier Transformers
titles the absence of Academy
award-winning actors Hamming it up with
Optimus primal doesn't inherently make
rise of the Beast a bad movie however
the dissonance of actors like Hopkins
sharing the screen with CGI robots was
amusing enough to make it deeply miss
when it's suddenly gone from the
franchise
go back and look at the designs of the
robots in the original Transformers
movies and try your hardest to discern
who is who in any given action scene
across the Original Trilogy of
Transformers films the default color
scheme for the Decepticons was gray over
a grayer gray the Autobots had more
varied color palettes but their
over-designed appearances made it
impossible to figure out crucial details
about the characters while Transformers
age of Extinction and Transformers The
Last Knight tried to streamline the
robot designs and utilize more primary
colors and their looks they still
Blended together in chaotic action
sequences Transformers rise of the Beast
thankfully after much more simplified
robot designs villainous characters like
Scourge are still decked out in subdued
colors but it's much easier to discern
the anatomy of individual robots the
various maximals are extremely
distinctive looking compared to one
another it's also a pleasant surprise to
see characters like RC and Mirage have
such vibrant Hues while even the
villainous nightbird gets a purple color
scheme well not quite as pleasing
looking as a very classical design seen
in Bumblebee the designs of the
Transformers and rise of the base are
welcome departure from the older
Transformers features price of the base
is another period piece this time around
the Transformers are shown interacting
with earth and its people in 1994.
initially director Stephen cable Jr
seems quite Keen to emphasize that rise
of the Beast is in tune with the world
of 1994. thanks to elements like kids
wearing Mighty Morphin Power Rangers
t-shirts however as The Story Goes On
the 1994 setting becomes increasingly
inconsequential to the movie by the time
the action sheds to Peru and focuses on
stopping the arrival of Unicron rise of
the Beast could be set in any time
period This is a disappointing element
of the movie but it's especially strange
since the Michael Bay Transformers
movies were very much rooted in the time
periods they were made in with so many
of the Transformers movies being rooted
in very specific eras it's a Pity rise
of the Beast quickly loses interest in
making use of its 1994 setting
the original Transformers exceeded a 145
minute run time and the sequels only got
longer from there the peak run time of
The Saga was read for the 2014
installment Transformers age of
Extinction which ran for a staggering
165 minutes really yeah yeah long time
thankfully Transformers rise of the
Beast is one of the shortest live-action
Transformers movies at just 117 minutes
even though it's much shorter than
Transformers the last night rise of the
Beast certainly could have withstood
some further Cuts in the editing room
but check the Lee in a slow second act
that is far too heavy on Exposition
pacing issues notwithstanding the length
of Rise of the Beast is an incredibly
welcome deviation from the runtimes of
the Michael Bay Transformers movies
the first Transformers movie was
released five years before the Avengers
popularized shared universes because of
this base approach to big budget movies
and Transformers has never really
included rampant sequel teasers his
Transformers movies could feature
lingering plot lines to be dealt with
later but typically his stories function
to Standalone Enterprises the ending of
Transformers rise of the Beast
unfortunately makes the open-ended
conclusion of age of extinction look
extremely subtle by comparison this
ending suddenly introduces a GI Joe
methos into the world of Transformers in
the hopes of kickstarting a new Hasbro
Cinematic Universe it's an unwelcome
departure from the willingness of
earlier Transformers movies to at least
end on a definitive note rather than
retroactively turn a preceding movie
into a feature lens trailer
from the very beginning the Michael Bay
Transformers movies didn't want to be
seen as just family movies as a result
the features bolstered their respective
screenplays with plenty of edgy humor
meant to tell adults in the audience
that this was a movie meant for them
I am directly below
taking a cue from the creative impulse
is a bumblebee rise of the Beast let's
choose Tendencies towards crudeness and
shallow ideas of adult humor more the
film doesn't talk down to audiences or
prove unengaging to older viewers it
happily proves appropriate for younger
viewers to watch it also doesn't derail
its plot line with weird attempts to
prove how Majora's sense of humor is
which helps make the pacing far more
consistent ironically by avoiding edgy
humor aimed at grown-ups rise of the
Beast comes off as a far more mature and
confident production the early
Transformers movies appeared a little
self-conscious when it came to embracing
every corner of the source material but
there is a slight shift in Transformers
rise of the Beast the very presence of
the maximore suggests that the
franchises move closer to acknowledging
the ridiculous parts of Transformers
lore unfortunately the more ridiculous
pass of Rise of the Beast underscore how
the rest of the movie is still too
devoted to realism human beings still
get the Lion's Share of screen time
instead of the robots major characters
like Unicron are still drained of the
primary colors they have in the comic
books and too much time is spent on
trying to provide rational explanations
for story elements like why the maximals
are on earth the Transformers movies
still feels self-conscious enough to
overwhelm the audience with Exposition
justifying its outlandish qualities and
that feels like an extra strange
maneuver when there's a robot gorilla
stomping around on screen
foreign
[Music]